all right buddy let's get into this we
got a whole bunch of stuff all right
price where are we at around low 40
thousands yeah so like the first chart
you'll see are just some price levels i
drew out so
last week we talked about i started
buying around 41k
and the reasoning is just because
i saw a 40k is just a you know really
clear kind of macro support level it was
a prior higher low that we hadn't
retested yet
and so you know at a minimum you should
be expecting a bounce off of the first
retest of a macro higher low so
did start buying as i talked about last
week got a nice little reaction off of
that um and now it appears that we were
setting some kind of high or low um
posted this this morning or took the
screenshot of the chart this morning at
like 40 to 500
from there from this area that i was
looking at for a little uh bounce or you
know a little micro kind of higher lower
here um we have seen a little bounce up
to what are we at now like 43 to 200 so
i've seen like a nice little seven eight
hundred dollar bounce off that area so
um does look like we're sitting a little
higher low here on kind of
microstructure which is a good sign of
course um you know i'm still chilling in
spot
i think the first area to look at is
this prior range low call that around
like 46k to be specific like 45 7
and see kind of how derivatives look
there um and then from there you know if
let's say you know it looks like you
know perps perhaps are fading the rally
then you know maybe we get a little move
up to prior range highs but i'm just
kind of playing it level to level um for
now but yeah still chilling in in my
spot bias that we talked about last week
but this is just what i'm looking at
from you know purely just a price
structure standpoint
all right so that makes a lot of sense
in terms of where we are right now one
of the things that you've been talking
about for a while now
that has maybe not concerned but like
it's definitely worth paying attention
to is this open interest and in today's
newsletter
you call out that it's still high so
explain
why this is important for people to
understand and what this potentially
could mean in terms of volatility in the
future
yeah so last week i felt like we that
might have been the longest that we've
ever recorded we went pretty in-depth in
terms of um describing open interest and
funding and some of these uh you know
derivatives metrics
but you know for anyone maybe who wasn't
listening last week open interest at a
high level is just
if you want like a bit more nuanced
explanation you know feel free to look
at last week's video i just don't want
to like reiterate it for people that
were listening last week um yeah open
interest is just looking at the amount
of open contracts so there's you know
always balanced out in terms of how many
longs and shorts there are open interest
just tells you how many of those
contracts are open um and so we we are
still in this kind of
uh area where you know prior prior you
know previously the last four or five
times that we've been in this upper area
we have seen a flush after that so it's
basically showing you like this is a an
area where you know open interest is
building up sufficiently that you know
you get some kind of wipe out and that's
not necessarily a bullish or bearish
thing um you know as as we've seen in
may you know that was a
a sign that you know longs were really
aggressive we got to wipe out the end of
summer though you know those aggressive
shorts that built up and so we had a
short squeeze so it's just telling you
that
the contracts are built up but it
doesn't tell you about the positioning
so we still do have a lot of leverage
built up um as you can see in the last
like kind of 24 hours we've actually
started to wipe out a little bit of the
open interest on this move up
um and so perhaps that you know it's
showing you that you know
shorts are starting to close out on this
move up
um but yeah i mean we're still still
very high we still wiped out a minuscule
amount of oi compared to what we've
built up over the last month you know
call it like uh maybe like a fifth of
the oi we've built up over the last
month so yeah still expecting some
volatility in that sense um and some
some you know major kind of liquidation
event that we've been talking about for
a while but you know i'm still waiting
on it i keep i keep posting like on my
twitter like when when squeeze that's
yeah that's what i'm referring to i'm
just waiting for this metric to wipe out
of this kind of overheated area one of
the things that you've included in here
is this bitcoin entity adjusted dormancy
flow and i started to see more people
talking about this i know you've been
talking about it a few others and then i
recently saw one of the guys at fidelity
start posting about these dormancy flows
as well uh help people understand in
terms of why this is important and i
think the key piece is this is only what
the fifth or sixth time that this is
kind of flashed a signal uh throughout
the lifetime of bitcoin which is you
know it's it's very rare so it's
important to kind of pay attention and
understand what's happening here
yeah shout out to the guys at fidelity
i'm happy to happy to teach him a thing
or two
all right so what is this
respect to that guy durian on uh on
twitter i like his stuff but yeah so
this is looking at um dormancy which is
based off destruction and destruction is
kind of a cornerstone metric of engine
analytics so like the example i always
use to explain this is like if you have
a one coin you move it into your wallet
you hold it for 10 days you've now that
that coin while sitting in that wallet
has now accumulated or created 10 coin
days
depending on when you move that coin out
that's telling you the amount of coin
dates that are being created so you know
for simplicity purposes for this example
the coin is moved into the wall it sits
there for 10 days 10 coin days are
created you now move the coin out of the
wall now those 10 coin dates that have
been created are now destroyed and
that's where the term destruction comes
from
so if you think about this by definition
destruction is what we call coin days
destroyed you know same thing
is going to be high when there's high
volume right because you have a large
amount of coins that are being traded so
you're going to see more coins being
spent or more destruction when there's
high volume um and so the way to adjust
for this is dormancy dormancy adjusts
coin day's destroyed for volume to just
give you the raw value of destruction
itself
and so we take the uh annualized dollar
turn like the the dollar denomination of
dormancy so the annualized dollar
denomination of dormancy and compare
that to bitcoin's market cap and that's
where we get this dormancy flow
and so essentially like from first
principles like just the like high level
of what this is telling you it's just
that there's a slowing of smart money
spending their coins so in bull markets
as we talk about often with like the
long-term short-term holders you see the
you know the smarter money which
when i'm saying smarter money i'm
referring to you know more experienced
market participants they sell their
coins or scale out into strength and
they accumulate back into weakness
and so this is kind of a similar way of
looking at that that dynamic so you'll
see dormancy peaks when we're you know
in these in these uh kind of bullish uh
you know market market structure periods
um or periods of market structure i
should say um that so that is showing
you that the older the older you know
more experienced markets are spending
their coins then heading into the bear
market you'll see this declines meaning
that you know those older those same
older you know experienced market
participants aren't spending their coins
as much because biscuit bitcoin is at a
discount um and so you know in when we
look at like long-term holder supply we
actually see that they're accumulating
this doesn't show that they're
accumulating it just shows a lack of
spending uh and so again
like this is from first person was just
telling you there's a decrease in
spending from those you know older more
experienced market participants whenever
that decreases a substantial amount we
push into this little buy zone that's
highlighted at the bottom
in this in this green area so yeah we've
we've only reached this five times uh
this is the sixth time that we've
entered this zone um so you'll see you
know at the bottom of i think this is
late 2011 here on the left
um 2015 at the very bottom of the bear
market as we whipped down that final
wick down at the you know at the bottom
of the 2015 bear market uh at the 2018
bear market at the very low as well as
during the coveted crash and then the
most recent one was over summer at the
very bottom at the end of july we
briefly whipped into the buy zone and we
are entering this now
um and so you know for for like longer
term investors this can be used to say
okay like look i'm just gonna scale my
bison more heavily as we enter the zone
right uh because it you know once we
enter the zone
you know we may have like slight you
know maybe 15 20 percent more downside
to go
um so theoretically like if we reached
the bottom of the buy zone we'd be at
like 30k so you know this is telling you
like this is a good time to start
scaling and start scaling and buys for
longer-term investors for people who are
like more momentum-oriented you can go
to the next chart which is looking at
when when dormancy comes out of the buy
zone so you know some people i saw some
comments which are completely completely
valid saying like well why wouldn't i
just wait for this to come out of the
bison right because then it's showing
you that we're coming out of that
capitulation area we're coming out of
the bottom
that's completely valid um it's just
that you know you're approaching the
market differently instead of averaging
in your buys at the lows you're waiting
to see when the market is like coming
off of the lows starting to regain some
momentum off those lows
and it does appear over the last day you
can see we're we're barely poking out of
there but it looks like we are beginning
to start uh to begin to exit the uh the
buy zone here at the bottom so it's that
you know something to keep an eye on if
we if that continues over the next
couple days um i think it sticks i think
it's a little premature to just call
like the first day it just starts poking
out but if we do start to see this move
out over the next couple days i do think
that's you know a valid signal to say we
are coming out of the spy zone but yeah
yeah again only as flash six times in
bitcoin's history um and it's just
essentially telling you that the you
know longer longer term more experienced
you know market participants um are
slowing down their spending and have you
know decreased the spending of their
coins we can see this in other metrics
too like uh long-term holder supply they
started to distribute their coins a bit
when we when it looked like we were
about to re-break all-time highs up to
69k on this move back down over the last
month or two they have decreased their
spending you have started to see what's
what we call long-term holder net
position change showing you you know the
basically the the 30-day change of
long-term holders uh holdings um we have
seen that flip green over the last week
or so and then as well we've seen things
like uh average spent output lifespan
looks at the average age of the coins
being spent um these all these different
kinds of metrics are all basically
telling you the same thing that this one
is
so
i want to skip ahead real quick uh to
the graph that you have here of the
supply held by retail and i think that's
a good place for us to kind of wrap up
because what you're talking about here
is uh with these dormancy flows is like
there's only happened so many times
right this is the sixth time this has
ever happened but regardless of high
prices low prices uh you know whatever's
happening in the macro environment et
cetera this chart that we have around
the supply held by retail it's just
straight up and to the right and is it
fair to say that looking at this
visualization tells us that retail
doesn't care about the price they just
continue to kind of dollar cost average
into this or do you read it some other
way
yeah exactly if i was you know
looking to you know present bitcoin as
an asset class that's like a 10 15 year
long investment to some you know
investment fund like i would show this
chart this would be one of the charts
that i would present and the reasoning
is because it's showing you that over
time there's a cohort of people that are
steadily dca into the asset no matter if
it's up down sideways whatever i mean
the chart literally goes up into the
right
um and so you know retail doesn't have a
substantial impact on the price in the
short term but over the long term they
definitely do
and so what you'll see is obviously
retails holdings increase more so in the
bull market because there's you know new
market participants that come in uh but
there is this you know a fair amount of
those of those uh market participants
leave in the bear but you do see that
you know there's some stickiness there
where this continues to grind up in the
bear market just at a at a slower rate
than than during the bull so if you look
at you know 2011 if you look at the two
2013 double pumps if you look at 2017
you'll see that the rate of increase of
retail holdings goes up but even after
you know the the you know blow off top
euphoria um the you know this does
continue to slowly grind up and so the
way i kind of see this is like
number go up technology as we like to
call it as bitcoiners um you know it's
the kind of best form of marketing for
bitcoin draws in new market participants
and some of those market market
participants that are just complete
speculators and are coming in because
the price is going up they
they leave you know whenever the number
go up fund stops right
but you do see that during that period a
fair amount of those market participants
do educate themselves about the asset
class understand the value proposition
over the 10 you know 10 15 year long
period plus um and they do continue to
you know dollar cost average into the
asset over time so
um this is just showing you that over
time in in uh
and this is one of like the biggest
criticisms of bitcoin is like you'll be
hear people say like
you know a large percent of supply is
held by a small portion of people this
is really complete nonsense so a because
you know of this chart here which is
showing you that over time retail is
taking up a larger portion of supply so
the trend is in the right direction
b you know they always like to show you
like the top 10 bitcoin addresses and
then compare that to the overall
circulating supply of bitcoin and how
much those addresses hold that's a
terrible way to look at it and it's just
like either intellectually dishonest or
lazy in my opinion um
and the reason is because it's like
analogous to saying like
you know the the usd circulating supply
distribution is is bad because a large
portion of it is held by banks it's like
yes like it's helped it's held by banks
but banks are holding those dollars for
millions and millions of people in the
same sense that you know you're seeing
whales which are actually custodians or
exchanges holding bitcoin for hundreds
of thousands if not millions of
individuals so you know that's not even
shown in this chart this is just showing
you people that are taking custody of
their bitcoin and cold storage but it's
you know again even like this doesn't
even take into account the fact that a
lot of a lot of retail tend to you know
hold their hold their bitcoin on uh
custodians with custodians or or other
exchanges and so
you know that that fud around bitcoin
supply distribution just is is
inaccurate and um you know it's just not
taking into account any type of nuance
whatsoever
you're killing it man what what two
questions you guys got
uh
will what about hash rate i saw you
tweet about it earlier that you know
ashrae is hitting an all-time high again
and network's more secure than ever but
how do you think about that when it
comes to price or like kind of network
adoption is that something where it's
just hey healthy to check on every once
in a while make sure the network is
getting more secure and stronger or do
you think that it has some kind of uh
adjacent connection to price over like a
shorter period of time also
so you know first of all i think um
before talking about price uh i think
it's really incredible just to think
about the recovery of hash rate since
the summer i mean think about it you
know we had a one of the you know most
important countries in the world um
definitely in the top three that you
know came out and said that they were
banning bitcoin mining
we saw all that hash come offline and
come back online in a completely
decentralized uncoordinated way you know
it wasn't like there's like a you know
bitcoin organization or bitcoin company
telling people to you know redistribute
their hash here and here and plug it
back online and helping them you know
it's just completely the network uh just
completely you know put itself back
together um through you know just this
uh completely decentralized manner
you know in that sense it's really
incredible to see that um and it also
eliminates one of the biggest um you
know fuds or criticisms around bitcoin
which was always that like the majority
of hatch rate was held by china and that
could propose some existential threat to
bitcoin um it's you know it's funny like
the same people that were making that
argument were the same people that were
like oh look all of bitcoin's hash rate
came offline it's like you can't have
bulk man like it's one of the other
uh and this is just shown to those
people that you know that bitcoin is
extremely resilient um and yeah again
like showing that uh bitcoins the
security around bitcoin is at an
all-time high so this also uh you know
one could argue that bitcoin is more
valuable because you know the security
is higher uh in correlation to price um
i think like that's one argument that
people will make
um i do think it's kind of like a
chicken or the egg or the egg of the
chicken right like it's
er
i think follows price in my opinion just
because the interest to mine bitcoin
follows the price appreciation of
bitcoin um some will argue the other way
but i think it's one of those arguments
where it's like you know it's just the
chicken is chicken before the egg or the
egg before the chicken gotcha john well
so when we think about that those retail
holders that you were talking about that
consistently are growing based on the
distribution of bitcoin how does that
fit into the macro sense of adoption so
we've seen a few things come out
recently brazil this morning but how
does that all fit into like the whole
view of bitcoin
yeah again i mean i think this just
shows you that there's you know the the
user growth of bitcoin is just up and to
the right over time accelerates during
periods where bitcoin's price is
appreciating right but even during the
bear market that continues to grind up
you see the same thing in just the raw
number of users on the network right so
if we look at something like uh net
entity growth and so it's looking at the
you know amount of new entities coming
on the blockchain versus the inactive
ones that hold no bitcoin and aren't you
know active on the network at all and
looking at the difference between that i
mean that metric as well trends up and
to the right over time um and so yeah i
i completely agree i think this is just
another thing to throw in the bag of
with some of those other metrics in
terms of um showing that over time you
know bitcoin is being adopted more so
more so um you know we got like el
salvador uh over the last year i think
uh the bitcoin bond might be an
interesting catalyst in terms of if that
thing gets oversubscribed which i don't
know about you guys but i think uh
there's a good chance that it does get
oversubscribed too i think you'll have
other countries that are uh you know
having a having a close eye on that i'll
say um and yeah i think um you know
that's that's another uh potential
catalyst for even more more user growth
um but yeah i mean i i think like over
time you're just gonna see this continue
to trend where it's going and that's
just up and to the right as
new people look to
um you know use bitcoin to you know
protect their wealth uh and as you know
the value proposition increases as you
can see continuing to see currency
debasement around the world so
especially in these you know um
you know these countries that aren't as
fortunate as like the us right like a
lot of people in the u.s see bitcoin as
like
purely a speculative asset right in
which a lot of money managers in the us
do see that
and so uh you know they just see bitcoin
as just like a risk on speculative play
and you saw like a lot of just
uh de-risking over the last two months
as we saw risk off behavior and equities
because of you know the fed talking
about monetary tightening which we still
haven't done anything but they've been
you know talking about tightening
monetary policy but you know over the
you know overseas if you're currency's
debasing that you know 40 50
uh a month you know that that's
completely different like you need
bitcoin to to you know preserve your
wealth it's just you know i think in the
in the u.s we're very privileged uh and
you know some of the people that are
baffled like how come we see user growth
on bitcoin when price is down so much um
you know i think you really need to try
to put yourself into you know shoes of
the less fortunate uh in other countries
where you know maybe they you don't
actually have the reserve currency as
your native currency
very true well
where we stand right now
when you think about how you're
allocating your own personal capital
this is not financial advice for anybody
else but have you changed anything in
terms of uh what you're personally doing
no again like um last week we talked i
bought
around 41k on the retest of
uh that macro uh higher low which is at
40k
um
mr i didn't snipe the bottom right again
i got it i bought around 41
but yeah i'm still chilling in that and
chilling in spot i think we
you know at least get a move up to
you know the prior range lows which is
around 46k we'll reevaluate there we'll
see what derivatives uh you know
structure looks like and then
either i think we probably set a kind of
macro lower high there or we can push up
to the 53k area maybe set a lower high
but i mean um the way you know the way
i'm i'm kind of evolving my thinking now
is just i'm just looking at things from
level the level right and we'll see
when we get to the next level and we'll
reevaluate there but yeah for now i'm
chilling in the in my spot buys from
last week haven't haven't touched them
all right and then we do a quick uh
follower account you guys know how many
followers will has now 600 550 000.
let's get it
just hop into the right man you you uh
what you gained 50 000 followers in the
first two weeks of uh january or so
something crazy like that um you know i
wanna
i wanna start doing a bit more like
education in terms of i think like a lot
of times we talk about this stuff on the
show or i'll post about it on twitter
and it's just you know there's a lot of
jargon and i understand it seems
confusing so starting next week i'm
going to start doing like a video series
and we can we could talk offline about
maybe uh working something out between
the two of us to collab on this but
we're doing some like kind of
educational series on on the different
metrics that we talk about so you're
going to basically break down hey here's
what the metric means here's how to
evaluate it and do like pure education
on it yeah exactly like you know 10-15
minute video on each metric and just go
through and just knock them all out and
do like a series of those yeah i think
that's a no-brainer to do
it's very smart
i think it's a win-win for all of us
right because then it makes it easier
for me for people saying you know i
don't know it's jargon or whatever and
then it also helps other people
understand stuff so that's it's great
all it's great all around i completely
agree with that
all right my friend we will talk to you
again next week keep up the great work
uh you have uh for months now almost a
full year actually kept uh kept everyone
informed so keep up the good work and uh
every time we talk i just i appreciate
the fact that i can tell that you're
doing a lot of learning in between the
conversations so keep working hard and
there's a lot of people who are counting
on you so
you only got all the answers but you got
a couple which we appreciate
thanks brother yeah thanks for having me
on as always and uh yeah i mean i'm just
you know learning making mistakes and
trying to share what i would have
figured out along the way like everybody
else so
appreciate appreciate the time and um
you know i'll see you next week man all
right sounds good buddy later all right
take it easy guys bye